hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
sporulation that is the process through
which certain types of bacteria can go
to form endospores if you're interested
in learning more about endospores see my
video on that topic now when
environmental conditions become
unfavorable for example when the
bacteria is experiencing some form of
starvation or extreme temperatures it
may begin the process of score ulation
this is when you have replication of DNA
so you have a bacterial cell wall plasma
membrane cytoplasm inside that and some
DNA then the DNA also the plasma
membrane against pinching in to separate
off a little bit of the cytoplasm as
well as the newly replicated DNA this
pinching in at the plasma membrane is
the beginning of the formation of a
spore septum then you have later
completion of the spore septum from more
plasma membrane tension
this results in something called the
forespore so the precursor of the spore
or end of score this is composed of a
double membrane and then this pink layer
that you see is peptidoglycan so
peptidoglycan fills the space between
those two membranes
after that reason score code for a year
at this point noms for DNA original DNA
is replicated maybe it's greener it is
left and at this point the endospore is
released from the dying cell in tow
spores can last for centuries before
they germinate or return to their
reproductive vegetative state where they
can where the bacteria can then continue
to grow and even cause disease if you're
interested in learning more about how
endospores me visualize under a
microscope see my video on the spore
stain if you're interested in learning
about how bacteria grow in their
vegetative state so once they have left
there in those four state see my video
on binary fission and bacteria grow but
that's it for today on the topic of
score ulation thank you for watching and
I hope you learned a lot